Jason if someone came to you and said
they are serious about starting a
YouTube channel and YouTube business
what would you tell them well they do do
that quite often daily every other day
weekly I say don't do it for I want to
make I want to make a lot of money I
want to be famous um do what you think
is great and interesting and and genuine
to you first and then the rest of it if
you do that the rest of it will come you
know if you put in the time I mean the
competition the amount of content that's
uploaded every minute keeps growing and
it's pretty daunting so all you can do
is be like I love this I think I think
the world needs to see this and YouTube
is a great place for that so do that
first and always do that and the rest
the rest will come so that being said
suppose someone is acting in their own
artistic self interest and then what
would you tell them they should expect
in the first three years because I know
things have gotten so competitive like
2016 oh yeah it's I mean it's not if it
was easy everyone would do it and
everyone would be successful hard is a
relative term because if you love it
it's not hard and it's not work but you
know making a video and uploading it and
then being like the world's going to
love this I love it it is is the easy
part it's doing all the things it takes
to get people to care and you know I I
say all my like kind of social media
sites like my babies and I gotta burp
them and feed them and tell them i love
them and then you know relationships
with blogs and other youtubers and other
Creators is like kind of like my social
life so there's a lot of things that you
have there's a lot of upkeep you know
putting up make it i wish it was easy as
like I got a good idea of a film a video
and put it up and walk away that's the
easy part the the difficult part is the
upkeep you have to do every single day
to to keep all your kind of properties
um in front of people's faces as much as
possible without annoying them would you
say there's any baby mama drama do you
ever have trolls and different things
that you are to either respond to in a
kind way or put in their place you know
I'm kind of known for I'm always really
good at responding to people's comments
oh uh I went a lot of favor that way but
I do you know some people just don't
like things I get a lot of hate
well things in fact a video series
called gay reactions because since 2009
I've been getting things whether it's
like you know people think these videos
are real which is great they're like why
didn't you have sex with that girl she
wanted have sex videos like you know in
my mind a sex tape it's a video with a
joke and they they believe it's real so
much and then you know i'm just very
comfortable with myself so I make very
like remarks I make so people just are
pretty hateful with you know gay bag
whatever they want to say and but you
know what they're commenting they're
watching they're engaging if you're not
getting hate comments you're not you're
not doing as well as you should be
something but that way that's what I do
when you say you're getting all of your
properties in order yeah how much time
is actually devoted to you sending these
videos to bloggers or these different
sites you know some some people are
pretty lucky where they're their
subscriber base takes care of a lot of
stuff I don't trust in that you know
they you know you tues always kind of
work and make self better so I don't
trust that all you know my subscribers
are going to take over I you know I find
blogs that I have relationships with and
and that that that target certain things
which I spent a lot of time either
making relationships or contacting
people and it's free content for them if
you know it's it's they're putting it up
you're getting the you know it's
embedded you know that's my you know I
want it embedded and so I'm getting the
traffic you have free content that
people are going to enjoy and they're
making money off their ads and then it's
a lot of posting on you know you know
social media sites if it's a
collaboration which you know I'm kind of
known for its getting the people i
collaborate with it's like hey you're in
this can you promote it and that's like
a huge key in kind of getting sharing
audiences because you want to share
everyone wants to share audiences you
know you can't everyone can't share
everyone else's audience because it
really cool you know dilute things and
people be like you're showing me too
much but it's kind of finding that
balance that's key do you think people
are under the impression that oh wow I'm
just making videos and being creative
all day when most of its actually
administrative work in terms of like
putting stuff on social media or on like
chill calm or whatever you know it's
yeah that's that takes more of the time
is it like putting up the video is e I
wish we'd stopped that and even you know
at some meetings that you know YouTube
or Google you know people spend a week
making a video in like five minutes like
on the you know the metadata the tagging
the title the thumbnail and all the
other stuff when you know that that's
where that would you know great videos
have not been seen just like great songs
have not been her great books have not
been written but there's amazing videos
out there that no one will ever see
there's terrible videos out there that
everyone will see so you have to UM you
have to do that you know you have to do
that work unless you can find someone to
find someone to help you but um you know
no one no one pushes promotes and is a
better PR person than I am for myself I
know my work and I know my worth and I
know what I I know what I do so I just
when I put up a video I spend the time
but I know we spent the majority that
day you know doing what I need to do to
get it out there
you